in this video I want to talk about a
sort of general overview of what's
supposed to happen in fatty acid
synthesis without actually talking about
the actual reactions of it so beta
oxidation was breaking down fatty acids
so here we're talking about building
them instead of breaking them down so
this is an anabolic process and if you
recall the catabolic process was beta
oxidation so the anabolic process would
be a reductive pathway so if it's a
reductive pathway it's going to require
a reducing agent and we're going to
require a specific reducing agent and
that is NADPH we'll talk about that in
more depth in just a moment but if you
recall fatty acid
breakdown beta oxidation we clipped off
a two carbon acetyl co a in every round
of beta oxidation in fatty acid
synthesis instead of breaking off acetyl
co is we're going to be putting acetyl
co eyes together to some degree of
course so where are the acetyl co a is
where is acetyl co a normally located
what's normally located in the
mitochondria mitochondrial matrix right
where pyruvate is converted to acetyl co
a via the pyruvate dehydrogenase complex
acetyl co a usually is in the
mitochondria but where does fatty acid
synthesis occur it actually occurs in
the cytosol okay so we need to somehow
get the acetyl co a out to the cytosol
now problem acetyl co a does not cross
the mitochondrial membrane and neither
does oxaloacetate okay both of these
compounds do not cross the mitochondrial
membrane however
those two come together this two carbon
molecule is four carbon molecule they
can form citrate and you should recall
that that reaction is catalyzed by
citrate synthase which is an enzyme from
the TCA cycle now citrate however
citrate can cross the membrane so
citrate can cross the mitochondrial
membrane so it does now once we have the
citrate out in the cytosol there's an
enzyme called citrate lyase which
actually can cut cuts the tray back into
acetyl co a and oxaloacetate now this is
good because now we have these acetyl co
a is available for fatty acid synthesis
in the cytosol so this acetyl CoA is now
ready for fatty acid synthesis however
now what with this what these acetyl co
a is need is they need reducing power
they need NADPH s so where do these
NADPH has come from
well this oxaloacetate that was created
can can be converted into male eight now
if you recall male eight is converted
into oxaloacetate via male 8
dehydrogenase and that was an oxidation
reaction in which we created in NADH in
this case we're going to go from an init
from oxaloacetate to to malate so that's
going to be a reduction reaction and
we're going to have to take NADPH and
convert it into nad plus now once we
have male eight male eight can become
pyruvate by losing a carboxyl carbon
dioxide and when we lose that carbon
dioxide
male 8 is being when it's converted to
two pyruvate it's being oxidized and
when it's being oxidized we're creating
a reducing agent you might have guessed
it already but what are we going to
create in this case we're
create nad loops and ad pH now this is
going to be important for fatty acid
biosynthesis right if you recall we
mentioned that NADPH could be created
from the pentose phosphate pathway well
this is another way that NADPH can be
synthesized now once it's been made in
the cytosol it can be used right can be
used
oops it can be used for fatty acid
biosynthesis
so these acetyl co a is right there
going to be you know sort of be put back
together to be made into a fatty acid
they're going to need reductive power
that reductive power comes from an ad pH
so if you recall beta oxidation had two
oxidation steps fatty acid synthesis has
two reduction steps in those two
reduction steps NADPH is is reoxidized
back into nadp+ so this is used for
those two reduction steps so I hope that
general overview about what's supposed
to happen with fatty acid synthesis was
helpful in addition I also hope it was
helpful that you can understand where
how this is another way to actually
create NADPH so like I said I hope that
was helpful thank you for watching